so if a system passes the touring test
it's not scientific
but uh in issues of philosophy things
like ethics start to enter the picture
do you think there would be
we would start contending as a human
species
about the ethics of turning off such a
machine
yeah I mean that's definitely come up
hasn't come up in reality yet but yet
but I'm talking about 2029 there's not
that many years from now
um so what are our obligations to it
uh it has a different I mean a computer
that's conscious it has a little bit
different uh
connotations than a human
uh we have a continuous consciousness
we're in an entity that does not last
forever
um
now actually a significant portion of
humans still exist
and are therefore still conscious
um
but anybody who is over a certain age
doesn't exist anymore
that wouldn't be true of a computer
program
you could completely turn it off and the
copy of it could be stored and you could
recreate it
and so it has a different type of uh
validity
you can actually take it back in time
you could eliminate its memory and have
it go over again I mean it has a
different kinds of
connotation than humans do well perhaps
you can do the same thing with humans
it's just that we don't know how to do
that yet yeah it's possible that we
figure out all of these things on the
machine first
but that doesn't mean the machine isn't
conscious
I mean if you look at the way people
react say three CPO or other uh machines
that are conscious in movies
they don't actually present how it's
conscious but we see that they are a
machine and people will believe that
they are conscious
and they'll actually worry about it if
they get in trouble and so on
so 2029 is going to be the first year
when a major thing happens right and
that that will shake our civilization to
start to consider
the role of AI yes or no I mean this one
guy at Google claimed that the machine
was conscious but that's just one person
right so it starts to happen at scale
well that's exactly right because most
people have not taken that position I
don't take that position I mean I've
used
uh
different things
like this and they don't appear to to me
to be conscious
as we eliminate various problems of
these large language models
uh more and more people will accept that
they're conscious
so when we get to 2029 more I think a
large fraction of people will believe
that they're conscious
uh so it's not going to happen all at
once
uh I believe that would actually happen
gradually and it's already started to
happen